climate activists head for an oil
terminal on the banks of the thames in
essex
they are protesters from the
controversial just stop oil group
the aim to break in and disrupt
operations get out mate come on
but security is ready
undeterred the rest try another route
eventually some glue themselves to the
wall and are
licensing and production of fossil fuels
we're not asking for everything to be
halted immediately we know that's not
possible
but just we just gotta stop it now
because
it's just only gonna get so much worse
earlier in the day another group stopped
tankers on a busy a-road infuriating
birds
one slows to talk and activists climb on
top the police will hopefully be here
soon and then you can be on your way in
like maybe two hours two hours
they are unapologetic
we have tried with marches we've tried
with petition petitions they have not
listened to us this has to be the next
step and we need to take opportunity of
the very small window that we have
several activists have blocked a road
nearby we know that the vast majority of
the british public really care about
climate change but a lot of them are
very angry at your methods absolutely if
i was in my car stuck in traffic for
this i'd be crossed too
but i have five children and i need to
know there's a future for them
how long are you going to stay here for
just stop oil has been doing this around
the country for weeks now
some local fuel shortages have been
reported but it's the inconvenience
that's too much for some they stopped
all our work
do you know how much they cost us
what are they achieving
well what they're saying is they want
maximum disruption to stop the
government extracting oil and gas yeah
but that's cooking all
right
they're mental they're just out in the
country to ransom the home secretary
pretty patel has called these activists
selfish fanatical and frankly dangerous
and the labour party has said there
should be an immediate nationwide
injunction on their protests but all the
attention and all the outrage
is very unlikely to stop them if you
don't get up you're going to find
yourself getting arrested they are also
unlikely to get what they want the
government has committed to more oil and
gas in the coming decades setting the
stage for a long drawn-out battle
hannah thomas peter sky news in perfleet
essex